so you're talking to a new guy and he
asks you
so what is it that you look for in a guy
like what kind of qualities do you like
in a man
let me tell you why you should never
answer that question up front first of
all the only reason a guy is going to
ask you that question is that he can
find the fastest way to get you hooked
because if he knows what you want he's
just going to be that person so rather
than give him a literal cheat sheet on
how to manipulate you i'm going to tell
you how you're going to answer that
question you're going to tell him
how about you show me who you are and
then i'll let you know if you're the
kind of guy i'm looking for
stay woke the truth is that plenty of
men out there
would ask the question
about what you're looking for in a man
because they actually want to know it's
not less honesty up front it's more tell
her
that true you should be totally clear
both of you
about what you're looking for what your
values are etc that's that's what you
should actually do and you could take my
advice even though i wasn't putting on
makeup as i gave it